the rel
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video all right my friends in this
video i will be discussing what could be
considered as a deleted scene from the
game of thrones season 8 finale
now as you all know the final season of
game of thrones was easily one of the
most divisive endings in television
history game of thrones is arguably one
of the greatest shows ever made however
when it came to the last few seasons of
the show fans were angered by how the
writers handled the ending of this
amazing story one of the many things
that really upset a lot of the fans was
what happened to jaime and cersei
lannister in the end now if you have
seen enough of my videos you already
know how i feel about this myself jaime
lannister was easily one of the most
hated characters in all of the game of
thrones at the beginning of the series
but as the show went on we started
learning different things about this
character that did make some of us start
to like him in one of the most amazing
scenes in the whole show jaime revealed
exactly why he stabbed the mad king in
the back
tell me
if your precious randy
commanded you to kill your own father
and stand by while thousands of men
women and children planned alive would
you have done it
he said he had done this because the mad
king was on the verge of burning
everyone in king's landing which back
then was about half of a million
residents so although jaime was known as
the kingslayer we found out he earned
that name for a good reason we also know
that jaime kept his vow to lady catelyn
stark
it's yours
i can't exist that's reforged from this
dark sword
you'll use it to defend that stark's
daughter
he also freed his brother lord tyrion
when he was facing execution from their
father not only that but he also left
his sister when he discovered she would
not be helping the north in their fight
against the night king and the army of
the dead
and you conspired with tyrion
the man who murdered our father without
telling me your queen i didn't conspire
you met with him in secret without my
consent you plan to promote my enemies
interests that is the definition of
conspiracy i pledged to write north
even when it looked like cersei would
have him executed he still walked out on
her he even went into the north by
himself knowing that alone could get him
killed as well and when the night king
and his army did arrive in winterfell
jaime stood right there on the front
line with everyone else willing to
sacrifice his own life for the greater
good of the realm
so in the eyes of most of the fans jaime
was redeemed
lord selman would pay his daughter's
weight in sapphires if she's returned to
him
but only if she's alive
her honor
unbesmerged
now we would never fully forgive him for
throwing brain out of the window but the
man had come a long way from who he was
at the beginning of the show
unfortunately it felt as if all of this
development was thrown right out of that
window with bran when we heard jaime
lannister say this
if not for yourself if not for her
then for every one of the million people
in that city innocent or otherwise to be
honest i never really cared much for
them
innocent or otherwise
not only was he running right back to
cersei again but as you can see he also
said he did not care about any other
residents living in king's landing it
was as if jaime was the king slayer once
again ruining what i believe was the
best character development in the show
now one of the other many things that
upset millions of fans was how jaime and
cersei died as you all know jaime and
cersei died down in the dungeons below
the red keep during dany's attack on
king's landing now based on what we saw
it looked as if jaime and cersei died
from the stones falling down on them
first of all i think i can speak for
most of us when i say we wanted to see
cersei suffer i think most of us were
hoping she would die some horrific death
i mean after everything she had done
over the years we certainly did not want
the screen to go black at the moment of
her demise but what's even worse than
this is the fact that it looked like
jaime and cersei could have survived if
they had only stood a few feet to the
right or left that was revealed in the
following episode when their brother
lord tyrion discovers their bodies later
that day we can see that most of the red
keep is still standing the fact that he
can even walk down here lets us know
jaime and cersei basically died because
of dumb luck well i don't know how many
of you know this but this was not meant
to be the original scene
now i do want to say what i am about to
read is not new information some of you
may already be aware of this
the reason i want to make this video is
because i never see anyone mention this
so i am assuming there are still a lot
of you who don't know what this scene
should have looked like on the screen
for those of you that don't know this
information was revealed after the final
season aired in fact the episode scripts
for the final season of hbo's game of
thrones are now available to read at the
writer's guild foundation library in los
angeles this script adds explanation
about jaime and cersei's death that is
missing from the episode on the bells
jaime and cersei find themselves stuck
in the lower dungeons that is below the
red key as you all know the ceiling
falls in leading to their demise however
when lorterion found their bodies during
the iron throne episode it was obvious
they could have survived if all they did
was stand a little further to the left
or right
this led some fans to believe based on
this background detail that all jaime
and cersei had to do to survive was
stand somewhere else well in the
original script for the bells and the
iron throne it says the dungeons were
actually overrun by drogon's flames in
addition to the crumbling ceiling what
it actually states is all of the skulls
have been blackened and scorched by the
extreme heat of the fires that raged on
for hours this little information would
have let all of us know that it wouldn't
have mattered where jaime and cersei
stood because the dungeons were engulfed
in flames for hours anyway not only that
but if cersei did die by being burned
alive i think that would have been a
much more satisfying death for us who
were hoping she would actually suffer i
guess the writers ultimately decided
against this because they still wanted
to show cersei and jaime's bodies when
tyrion found them later on they wanted
this emotional scene when he discovers
they died before they were able to flee
from the city i guess he wouldn't have
known for sure if he had only found
blackened skeletons instead of their
actual bodies buried under the stones i
still think they should have went with
their original version but maybe that's
just me either way it still doesn't
excuse how jamie and cersei were handled
in the final season although i guess
this would have been slightly better let
me know what all of you think down below
how many of you actually knew about this
original scene and do you think it would
have been better as always i want to
thank all of you for watching this video
i hope i will see you back here for my
next one have a great day everyone i
will see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you